[Music]
so hello nice such a full packed room
for may be borrowing size format but in
the essence 5 format can be interesting
can make fun and a quite essential
because you have data you want to store
it you want to access it and you want to
access it again maybe in a different
fashion and maybe somewhere else
that's where Apache Parque comes in
shortly about me I'm a data scientist I
work at a company dealing with
supermarkets I am an Apache arrow and
pocket PMC main project management
committee fancy word for maintainer and
I'm a heavy pandas user a my talk I'm
going to give you a short inside of the
history of perky where it's coming from
and why it was needed I'm going to give
you a more in-depth what the format is
about what makes the format special
stationed and portable and then it is
also one slide with code how you're
actually going to use it so you'll get
access to it Apache pocket is a five
format coming from the Hadoop space it's
call enough storage format basically
meaning everything is column each column
object another stored in the file and it
was invented 2012 by Claude are on
Twitter at Twitter
they were already see realized in a
binary format but they wanted to have
them stored more efficiently so that
they can also evaluate big large queries
on them and in 2013 they made a first
stable release of the format and just
some months later it became an official
Apache project and went into all of a
lot other how to best project and now I
scared a bit ahead of space and it's not
generally available and since last
fall's we have full support in Tyson and
C++ for sake
both reading and writing at the moment
it's a state of the art format in the
head of ecosystem if you have any kind
of big large chunk of data you want to
process
normally tutorials will they use parquet
for example in the spark tutorial I
think if you look at a data frame
tutorials like 10 minutes in they just
say okay we started with Jason but now
to make full use of all power use
parquet sadly they just ate use parque
de don't see it say why and that's a bit
why I'm going to give this talk to give
you a bit inside
what's their fancy about this format
parquet it says it's a corner format
meaning it makes vectorized operations
like if you have those fancy chips with
msse and every X on it really fast but
also because all the data in the column
which is of the same type and start
nearby you can also use like a more
efficient compressing there are three
stages of compressing the data and
packages the encoding which exploit that
they know what data is in there and
they're really effective they're cheap
but they assume some kind of some things
of the data and it's just ordinary
compression codecs which run afterwards
making it a good combination and really
fast compression not so slow with if you
just use normal compression algorithms
like chief it only and another important
thing of the Patchett package format
it's not only made for that you can load
and store data fast it's also made that
if you have a Korean you wanted a
variant on a big data set which is
available package that you can actually
actually exploit some things and a data
format that you don't need to dilute the
hold file but is you only know to you to
load the relevant bits which you need to
execute agree I'm going to bit more
detail and later and the last important
thing package language and framework
independent so it started off being used
by Twitter for Hadoop but it also used
it in GLaDOS Impala and it's now
available a lot more engines so that the
two typical habits of pack a it's why I
have this big SQL query engines that can
work on any file form on any files in
any file systems like hives and Jara
drill or so on they normally have
like political they directly say use
parquet to get the best performance out
of our engine and that's because they
can exploit the format and don't need to
load everything and the frameworks like
spark and how to MapReduce that it's two
common ones where you can use em parquet
where you actually get Tory said okay
use this the could maximum performance
nowadays there's also supported pandas
to replicate files and does have also
support so using perky size input and
output and also you there has been some
benchmarks and showing that you can get
it really good speed up and does because
already does it does not do all the
magic you can do with perky by already
does some of this and therefore you get
better partitioning or load less data
[Music]
now forty actually the essence of arcade
park is in essence what you look at a
user it's a fire residing on a some kind
of file system how did size SMRs free or
your local file system normally packet
size you don't normally get one file you
have a big job that reduces like ten or
hundreds of thousands of files and a
five-year packet data set is normally
just aside because the size of the mod
files
what parky has from the global
perspective each engine looked normally
at a packet file or data set as a group
of rogue groups row groups are have all
the same columns and all the columns in
a row group has the same length and a
row group is the highest level of
paralyzation you get normally if you
have 100 pack a 5 and you start reading
it again from a computational framework
it will look and assign one partition or
one job to Ichiro group and not to each
file often one file has for Oprah's one
in some other cases if I can contain
more than one in their image rogue group
we have those column chunks each chunk
is of the same type you have two same
number of rows and then number of
columns in each row group and each
column chunk is also made up of pages
pages are like the smallest unit you
have to load in a packet file
pages are normally about 16 kilobytes
big that's the unit where you're going
to do compression and encoding on and if
there's in the page a data point you
want to load you have to load the whole
page and this is really relevant because
if you evaluating if you're not logging
to full file but evaluating the query on
it package or provides on every level
statistics theory then if you have a
query which has workloads in it and they
sort on that condition you can check on
every level against the statistics if
this condition is true and then you only
need to load this part of the file and
depending on the greatest can bring you
down that you only need to load a single
page of a column chunk and then you only
do what do to work on that meaning that
you get a lot cheaper access to this
powerful file and in comparison to if
your whole file wants more monolithic
junk and was compressed at once and so
you can use also every compression codec
on there even if you if a correlation
codec doesn't have some kind of like
near random access support there's
compression and encoding encoding is the
thing which is cheap but also already
bring down your data a good bit in size
the exploit that you know the data and
they also make assumptions about the
data so typical thing what is assumed is
that there is some kind of repetition in
your data or that is some kind of
redundant information which you can get
away by doing intelligent encoding just
a reference I'm using the New York
technique data set to give you an
estimate about what RSI savings that's
kind of an average data set to have some
columns with repetitions in them with a
lot of repetition and some cons with me
no repetition the generates data set was
one point six gigabytes s CSV the most
basic encoding you can do in a file is
just don't do any encoding just eight
states of data is
this is very fast with one cross the
NSEP you it is just memory copy but if
you use this you're probably will be
limited by your I Oh meaning your
network devices to slow or your heart
that is not as fast as your memory so
you already want to invest a big royalty
PU and to store the data bit longer the
first on most important encoding is run
length encoding and bit packing and
coatings are always simple so the first
one bit packing is quite easy if you
store data and the maximum value is
maybe four then you only need two bits
to encode for me in case it's free and
then you're on YouTube it and then you
if you have an n64 you can just press it
down turn it into two and save that in
your file already gives you a good
number of savings the next thing if
you're assuming just some kind of
repetition you can use run-length
encoding run-length encoding means just
if you see some repetition then write
down its a repetition and it's won't
become like 200 times now and what Park
is doing we doing both of them at the
same time and we always going to
evaluate if it's worth doing like
writing down that we have a repetition
or the other case there's a literal run
meaning we just write out the data as it
is and as an example we look at this
data here in Gen 4 for we see that as a
maximum value of 1 meaning we only have
one bit of information to encode for
each value meaning that we can go down
to one bit
also in the first chunk there is no
repetition or there is a bit of
repetition but until they're not all the
same so it wouldn't be worth writing
down there as a repetition and because
of that which is writing down it's
literally it's literally run and it has
two values 1 0 1 0 and the second half
there is repetition all the values are
the same so we write down depth we set a
bit for repetition we write down there
are 4 values and we put a wonder and
[Music]
this is done always on junks of the data
and [ __ ] actually the base offset is if
you have eight repetitions of a value we
write down as a repeated run if it's
less than eight repetitions it's not
worth that it's actually less less
amount of data to write down that there
is the exact values and this is always
done for things like repetition and
definition levels that's an important
part of Turkey which I'm skipping in
this talk because it's kind of complex
but we have those two in the format to
support malleability that's definition
levels and repetition record so that you
don't have just columns of primitive
values but the column can be a list of
lists of lists and we can include that
simply with the repetition levels the
second most important and most used also
encoding is dictionary encoding if you
have worked with pandas categoricals
it's kind of the same the difference
here is not done on a global file of not
on data set level it's done on a rope
root level you take all the values you
have you assign each value a code and
then you store at the beginning of zero
group the mapping of value to code and
for every one you only use the codes and
as an example we have a list of colors
and to bring them down
we simply store them the column names at
the beginning and then have amount of
data where we just have to code for them
and these codes also only switch the
relevant bits we need so we can eat
because there's obviously some
repetition in these values and because
you don't need all orbits we are also
doing this run length and bit pecking
encoding here on the current section and
just doing this picking encoding we
already get down to a fifth of the size
of the initial data set and the amazing
thing is dictionary coding is normally
so cheap that if you're reading from an
SSD you can read this fly faster in
comparison if it were just safe as it
would be in memory
and that already gives you a good
benefit but in the end it assumes
there's a repetition of data and it
works only on the data types if they're
if they're really repeated if you have
like floating-point numbers which are
nearly the same the geocoding won't work
that good and for the cases where the
encoding do not work good or what we
even want to improve a bit more we
packing use ordinary compression
algorithms but they used after encoding
so we already brought down our data set
to a fifth of the size so we only have
to push a fifth of the data size to the
compression algorithm making the
compression of a cheaper then by doing
it directly there are four compression
algorithms currently in the standard if
you want more because of portability
reasons you have to extend the standard
the most dominant in there is snappy
because snappier already gives you good
size but it's really fast on the example
data set snapping and jiseop get you
about in the same direction of the
octave size gzip is a bit smaller but in
the end snappy is much faster also
there's a bit of portability it's a
bottle format but not all reader support
or compression codecs so snappy is
supported by everyone kisi the support
of everyone I said oh there are some
licensing issues so it's normally not
supplied by default and proudly is the
one which is new which gives you if you
have gzip normally it will always
improve on your TTIP but it's not
available on all engines so I think at
the moment it's only the Python and
impressed oh and the pro regress for all
how to best implementations is still
open and so the basic usages once you
start using 4k just use snappy if that's
the problem with performance dancing
again but at the beginning don't care
about and just you snappy so
another important feature which makes
pocket quite unique format is that it
supports great push down meaning that if
you have a complication of graph or an
SQL query on it then depending on the
engine you already can push down the
evaluation to do layer because doing i/o
expensive getting it faster gives you a
bit better performance but in the end
not doing i/o at all is the thing where
you get the most performance out of it
and column a format means parky if
you're doing something on package size
you only need to load the columns you
actually need meaning having a table and
we maybe have a gray which only wants to
evaluate all the yellow IDs where we
have a price and dollar we only need to
load
decree together and a green column and
can ignore everything else that's mainly
because we have a calmer format and the
other thing is when you want to skip
rows or road groups we generate relevant
files we have the the beginning I told
you that we have those statistics at
every level of my case file most
probably they are just minimum maximum
but they already can tell you which
group you don't need if we assume these
three rows on different row groups which
is the kind of assumption only for it's
like we can see that in the middle
column there is no dollar price so
through our query also can skip over
this data and as it's parquet we have in
the metadata at the end already all
locations of where column or column
chart begins and ends does we already
know where we have to skip we don't have
to read the data into memory and then
skip a memory but we already can skip on
IRA ulcers I mean that we will only load
it load the non shaded part of the file
here into memory which is much much
faster than loading the whole file and
then you doing the computation in memory
and
just as a comparison hockey files are
quite small this is the whole New York
texture data set for 2016
they're comparable to hdf5 a message
back there if you go here to do less
there bit smaller many to julienne
codings but I think depending on the
layout of HDFS I use the planet layout
here I think there are other layouts
where it compresses a bit better they're
in the same region how much how fast you
can read them is also quite good using
plain hdf5 is just really fast
I'd understand Schmucks with RAM disk so
there is no HD overhead and you can see
there hdf5 it's just immediately save to
disk whereas if you have formats have
compression it will take longer the good
thing about parquet I've showed you this
picture of the file structure at the
beginning and you can use the structure
to read everything in extremely parallel
meaning that you can read each column
chunk in plural or you can actually
decode every page in parallel because
you know how big each chunk will be in
number of rows you can already Prieto
create that and have several threads
reading at parallel meaning that reading
packet files and scales really good with
the number of CPUs was already four CPUs
you get to the base line of hdf5 but in
the end we have a quite fast
implementation here in Python but where
you can also see if you look at a
comparison of storage size whereas a
time to read it we have a good optimum
down here with 4 cores but also with
single core we stay in quite good I
obviously emitted omitted here
uncompressed hdf5 that's reading that
much faster but a storage size is also
like bitter bigger and for me it's the
most important issue pocketed valve is
the portability
that I have data and pandas can write it
out and really it may be again with
parlor drill to make extra grades on
that but having this benefit that is
also good in size and time and
comparable to other formats is really
nice and and was Eddie any words only
by-product being so fast mainly was
about portability there has to be some
code so reading a writing packet is
quite a simple there at the moment it's
available in Python right by Apache
arrow or if you want to pip install or
Condor install the package is called PI
arrow what you're doing you this pyro
package we'll call it applause
implementation read it entering Apache
arrow table and with the two pandas or
from pandas down here dry path you
convert an Apache arrow table to pandas
dataframe small it small tiny bit of
overhead but that's neglect able in
comparison to that what amount of coke
be safe
they're ready now to implementation
stairs the error implementation which is
best on packet EBP and there's a number
of s 1 from continuum called fast pocket
so I present prefer the upper one
because I wrote that but there are two
ones and we have a bit of competition
meaning that we always take care to be
forced because I just mentioned Apache
error why do we use it
Apache arrow is basically also
standardization of data frames across
this different system so you can pass
data data frames from system a to system
be without having the need to convert
something or may even it depending on
the language if you're passing from
Titan to maybe lower or so you don't
have to make any copies we used here
Apache arrow just to bring bindings to
pack a when we have basically a lot of
C++ code for the Bakke reader which is
really fast and a tiny bit of like 100
or 200 lines of code which do all those
methods in we have bread in C++ to
pandas and
[Music]
I could make a whole talk about prick
arrow we release the CEO point freed on
Friday so that's also included a new
pack a CBP release which you can check
out it's already on condo for it's not
on pipe I that will be on maybe Monday
or Wednesday if you have questions to
that you can ask me later but they talk
about packing so I'm skipping over this
and also it's not this project so
instead of the typical we're hiring
there's a get involved slide I will post
those slides on my Twitter account and
in the flag channel but get involved we
have not implemented all features of
package in pison yet and at the end you
can do a lot of stuff more at the moment
you can only load data frames and store
them again tasks already have some
optimizations that you only need load
the rogue groups you need but things
like very push down or not it
implemented in Python but that's the
thing if you want to ever a big queries
on it in a query engine that's what you
really need but it might be also useful
for someone in places yeah and that's it
[Applause]
question
the question was here the difference in
size between packing and hdf5
I'm not sure why this is could be due to
the layout of pandas because they're
different layouts you can store hdf5
files I would have expected that hdf5
and message packs will perform exactly
the same but you can start a time frame
differently in different hdf5 files and
i use the standard panel implementation
Pocky concern and values on every level
so if you have a list of lists you can
have a null list or you can have another
entries in lists because data is loaded
back in pandas pandas has only the float
notes at the moment integer columns of
mouse will be slowed column and pandas
Apache arrow doesn't have that so once
panda supports real never null values we
also have been done front parking in
pandas box filed and package files are
quite the same so I think it's a the
main difference is where your ecosystems
a bit so if you in harder if you have a
whole two works sponsored product they
will normally you prefer aux files and
other projects will preserve parquet
size but they're kind of the same format
not the same format they have different
things implemented but during the same
scope and they're doing the same things
and have same features from a user
perspective
plucky fights are normally on how to
file system so that's where they started
and that's where if you can normally say
the sides of the road croupier and if
you hide apply system the perfect rope
group size is how to files and block
size but you can have some somewhere
else so I'm using a lot of parking and
we don't have a how to fly system at our
company so it works very well so the
question was write performance for
different behaviors there's actually
only one way pocket size are right once
so you can't append to them and because
compression is done on these page levels
here and at the end of the file of the
metadata so you want to written the
metadata the file is done right
performance is quite good because
because you're doing all this
compression and encoding and because you
can even do that partly in peril we
don't have a full entire rule now it
goes quite well it's less than read
performance but my benchmarks it what
about 1.5 times the read performance
yeah the relation to the pepper format
is that server is just taking data as it
is a memory it takes the same bindings
in same five structures as a KETV PC
using to write down all five
but favors unstable and and package like
party has quite a has a specification
which is a bit discussed between
different teams and have several readers
and it's made for long term storage and
it may also made for these queries
pushdown things you can't do really good
for a push down in server and servers
may need to have a really fast exchange
if you on the same system but I want to
switch between our and Python also you
can yeah yeah
the question was the pipe language
support master feels at the moment only
lists of lists we have an open pool
request which is making like structures
of list or dictionary offs or things but
it will take hopefully a month but then
we have it there's always the
representation of license because if you
if you have a list of lists this is
normally an umpire array of Python
object so it's quite inefficient but you
can encode it the Apache aerostructures
can hold these things efficiently but
you can't exercise at the moment really
good so that's hopefully the thing that
comes with pandas two or pandas to is
quite honor long or rice
[Applause]
[Music]